– Hallihallo!
– Hey!
– Die Serie ist abgedreht.
– Nico, Glückwunsch!
– Und was ist das?
– Das ist eine Filmklappe. Ich hab sie von
meinem Chef geschenkt bekommen.
Das Team hat
auf der Klappe unterschrieben:
Beleuchter, Schauspieler, Aufnahmeleiter,
Ton, sogar der Regisseur.
– Das ist wirklich mal ’n
cooles Abschiedsgeschenk.
– Als ich mal Fahrer in einer
Filmproduktion war,
hab ich so etwas nicht bekommen.
– Vielleicht warst du einfach nicht gut genug
und alle waren froh,
als du wieder weg warst?
– Danke, dass du heute
den Abwasch machst, Max.
– Ah …
– Ich habe sogar in einer Szene mitgespielt.
– Was, ehrlich?
– Mhm.
Es war nur eine kleine Rolle,
aber es hat Riesenspaß gemacht und
ich hab sehr viel Talent.
– Nico, der Star.
– Es war das Ende einer Verfolgungsjagd.
Der Kommissar ist erschöpft und rennt
in einen Fußgänger. Ich bin der Fußgänger.
– Hast du Text?
– Mhm, ja:
Passen Sie doch auf!
Dann helfe ich dem Kommissar
wieder auf die Beine, er rennt weiter und
erwischt am Ende den Gangster
dank meiner Hilfe.
Was soll ich damit machen?
– Ich will ’n Autogramm,
bevor du berühmt bist.